so jake paul who is setting up all these  fights okay uh and his brother has said  before that he has aspirations to be a  president one day  jake paul comes out which by the way he  these guys have never talked politics  before they're not a  would you agree they're not necessarily  a political brothers where they're going  out there saying stuff about politics  but yesterday he puts out this tweet can  you put that up there he says uh  biden's accomplishments highest gas  prices  worst inflation plummeting crypto prices  highest rent prices ever created new  incomprehensible language which we don't  many people don't speak if you're  reading this and voted for biden and you  still regret it and you still don't  regret it then you are the american  problem that could literally be a gatsat  tweet yeah that's  oh that's true  i'm already a fan of this guy well we  just introduced you to this guy named  jake paul jake paul so jake meet cat got  me jake